If you're going to create a successful video cover letter,...
...it's important that you understand the steps involved...
...and carefully plan what you're going to say and how.
Keep it brief and to the point.
A one-minute video or less is enough.
Highlight the most important points the employer needs to know.
Show your personality.
Companies will hire you...
...not only because you have the right qualifications...
...but also because you're the right fit for the job.
Practice reading your script over...
...until you're comfortable with what you're going to say.
And remember, you sound more natural by not speaking too fast.
Use a room with good lighting to improve visibility.
Rid the room of any items that may be a distraction to the viewer.
You don't want waste paper or objects lying around.
Dress appropriately like you would in a normal interview...
...to make a good first impression.
Sit in a good posture and if you're standing, stand upright...
...without hunching or fidgeting.
Show from chest up for a good view of your face and body language.
Okay, setup is finished and you're ready to shoot the video.
Firstly, introduce yourself and position you're looking for.
Give a brief summary of your past experience and achievements.
Talk about what makes you stand out in your current position,...
...what makes you unique and why you're a terrific person to work with,...
...why you think you're the right fit for the job,...
...and why the employer should hire you.
What value will you bring to the organization if hired?
Finally, you close with a convincing ending statement.
So, be creative.
Make a video cover letter that stands out from the rest.